[Music]
right let's be honest pasta is
definitely a big midweek staple in the
ramsey household and for me there's
nothing better than a delicious hearty
one so this one is all about turkey
leeks tagliatelle finished with the most
amazing sage breadcrumbs trust me it's
going to be a big hit in your household
right
oscar come in let's go through the
ingredients pan down pan down fresh taco
telly that takes about 90 seconds to
cook ground turkey is a great
alternative from beef a lot lean as you
can see there's harlene fat in there
beautiful baby leeks shallots lemon
garlic touch of chili
bread crumbs and of course fresh sage
right capitan let's have 10 minutes on
the clock
right first things first get that pasta
water boiling and sometimes when it's
not boiling get some salt in there and
that will increase
the actual speed of that water boiling
really important a rolling boil
pans on nice and hot now
the secret here
is to get some really good color on that
turkey okay it's a very sort of lean no
fat
so we've got to be careful because we
need some butter and olive oil in there
to give it that nice rich flavor first
off
shallots sliced in half
and i'm going to use a couple of slots
because leeks also come from the onion
family take off the ends
okay
and then from there literally
just slice down now
flat on the surface and
slice
don't go too thin
because you want this temperature quite
high and if the pan's super hot
the actual shallots will burn
nice
now from there top and tail your leeks
that basically means just take the top
and the towels off okay and again
nice
long strands
too fine and they'll burn okay i want
those leeks literally spreading through
the pasta
top and tail make sure they're very very
clean
and again on an angle and just slice
through
as this cooks it will sort of open up
across and all those leeks will start
sort of almost shredding get that pan
nice and hot
okay roll around
and in with the
shallots
and our leaves now
roll that over
again i like to use all the pan
so
spread that out
that helps to caramelize let's get some
color on those leeks
a little touch of salt
a little touch of pepper
and just a touch of this early stage of
chili that'll give it a little bit of a
lift
now from there
start off with the garlic again
quite nice
chunks of garlic if the caramelized
it's fine
okay
if you slice them too thin again they're
going to burn so keep them quite chunky
and you'll see the way that they
caramelize in the pan on top of the
leeks
they're sort of they taste better
sometimes when you slice the garlic
super thin it gets very bitter
now touch more salt be generous
with the olive oil
okay and now i'm gonna start adding my
butter okay
why
the butter's gonna give it a bit of
richness okay
little flecks
of butter
all the way down i want color i want
caramelization and more importantly i
want the water out of those leaks
gas
up high
get your pan ready for your breadcrumbs
just put it on a nice
ring and just keep it nice and hot okay
but look at that down there pan down
oscar please
time
three minutes gone now
whack up the gas once we've got that
color
give that a little toss
so beautiful
flatten it again
and now we're gonna add the turkey okay
and all we do is just break this up
and hit it around the side of the pan
and you'll see that we're gonna get some
really nice color on that turkey and
that's why i added the butter and the
olive oil because there's no fat in this
turkey okay so it's super lean
so it is semi-healthy but we finish it
with a touch of cream to bring it
together to give some richness so open
up
the turkey and almost sort of run it
through your fingers and just sort of
sprinkle it it's ground turkey and
sometimes i put it in the freezer for
five minutes before i use it because it
helps get it really nice and crumbly
okay
and look you can see
now i've got the leeks caramelizing
underneath
i've got the garlic and the shallots
working a touch of chili in there and i
haven't just put one big clump of ground
turkey in there now from there
quick wash the hands
so my vegan friends don't complain
season the top of that salt
and pepper
okay
and then look get your lemon
and just zest that lemon
over that turkey that's going to give it
a little bit of freshness for the
lightness
okay
but underneath
have a look at these leeks okay
so beautiful
now i give that a toss and look
i'm getting that color in there now
beautiful really beautiful
so
don't worry about adding that olive oil
and that butter we need that little bit
of fat in there and it stops the turkey
from going dry
good
halfway right
okay
give that a really good toss now keep
that nice and flat okay the seasoned
beauty that chili's coming through
the
turkey
is nice and separate and it's taking on
those leeks there's onions and there's
garlic
and then from there
we'll put my pasta in okay
now this is a thin taglatelli you can
use usually penne papridelli but this is
a beautiful quick and easy literally 90
second
pasta bring it up immediately
i like to season the top and the bottom
of the water i'll explain why in a
minute
shake the pan stop it from sticking to
the bottom and then we've got this nice
salted rolling boil water and then i
like to season it on top as well so that
is really nicely seasoned
gas nice and high
right
one pan two pans working now we're gonna
get the bread crumbs working i start off
with a touch of olive oil to stop that
butter from burning then i put my butter
in so it goes nice and frothy
and then as it starts frothing up
okay i season that butter
and add my breadcrumbs in there
and that's gonna fry them to get nice
and crispy
a little bit of sage
roll up the leaves and just
slice the sage
nice and fine in she goes
and you'll see that really nice light
flavoured
sort of spicy crispy breadcrumb on top
of the pasta
the water's re-boiling
check the pasta again
i'm going to be using some of that pasta
water
still a little bit al dente another 30
seconds
now
look at the leeks
look at the turkey
what i'm gonna put in there now to bring
this together there's about a couple of
tablespoons of cream
gas still nice and hot
up high bring that up to the boil
and look i don't want it too cloy i
don't want it too heavy
but just
coat it with the cream
and now my bread crumbs
pan down pan down please just have a
look at that look they're frothing away
and going really nice and spicy a touch
of chili in there
some fresh parsley
rice at the very end
okay in with those breadcrumbs
it also helps to cool down that butter
and it gives a really nice creamy
texture now look at that that's where i
want to go
the cream has brought it together okay
all i do now is get my
pasta bring your pan over to your pot
lift
don't drain all that water off
okay
grab your pasta
i'm adding a touch more water that
water's now packed with the starch
rolling around
and this is where the magic happens i've
still got the heat in the pan
we'll go back on the heat
a touch more water
and look
beautiful
now
so important that we do not put too much
cream in there when you look at this
dish now it doesn't look like there's
hardly any cream in there
time please
good
and now i've got that nice creamy
texture the last 30 seconds of the cook
takes place in the pan so don't cook the
pasta completely inside the water take
it out earlier
and have the confidence to finish it in
that sauce
and look from there
we come into
finishing
into the center
it's nice
and spicy with that chili the turkey is
caramelized the leeks have melted the
garlic is sweet
and then literally on top at your
breadcrumbs
and they are so crispy and you just
literally drizzle that crunch
on top
and there you go
that is a beautiful delicious
incredible
turkey pasta
to all of you thank you for watching
ramsey intent if i went too quick i
apologize but slow it down
now don't forget to pick up ramsey and
ten cookbook inspired by this series and
trust me you're gonna come out a much
better chef and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to my amazing
youtube channel for more good luck